when learning a language content is key
if you can find content of interest you
will be motivated to spend the time with
it and to understand it better one of
the best ways to find authentic content
of interest is by importing it whether
you enjoy current events YouTube videos
about gaming or cooking blogs you can
import anything on link let me show you
how it's done
to import a lesson to link I click
import lesson on the home page and fill
in my lesson information this is the TED
talk the Schuylkill creativity and the
title of the talk goes here
next I add an image
the text and the original URL if I want
to share this import with others on the
lesson feed I can also share lessons in
the lesson library for other members to
learn from as long as the content is
copyright free to do this I need to
include an audio file and tags tags
categorize lessons and help other link
members find them easier so they should
be relevant and spelled correctly before
you save the lesson first set a level
you can choose from beginner 1 or 2
intermediate 1 or 2 or advanced 102 some
of the vocabulary in this TED talk is
difficult so advanced 1 is the most
appropriate if you want to add a
translation video script exercise or
attachment add them here in resources
the link importer extensions make
importing even easier the link to the
extension for Chrome Safari and Firefox
can be found in the my lessons tab here
once it's installed I can go to the page
I would like to import from click the
extension and it will automatically
import the text image and original URL
from that page to a specific course on
link you'll also notice that there are
media articles in your link feed these
are articles from popular news sources
that are imported for you when you click
on them use these built-in sources or
find your own websites blog posts emails
and even ebooks whatever you're
interested in it's hard to stop once you
get started try importing your own
content on link today happy linking